you probably keep hearing about the
Keystone XL pipeline that has a bunch of
people pressuring President Barack Obama
to accept or reject it but what is it
and what will it do
first let's talk tar sands they can be
found all over the world but are heavily
concentrated in Canada it's a mix of
clay sand and a Maratha Sea oil that can
be extracted the world's most prominent
climate scientists called it a carbon
bomb he warns exploiting tar sands will
be game over for the climate mining oil
from tar sands isn't like sticking of
straw in the ground and having oil
guzzle up to get the good stuff you have
to cut down forests and extract heavy
crude from an area the size of England
then to squeeze the oil out of the sand
you have to boil the ground which takes
huge amounts of water and energy from
the tar sands to your car tank this oil
produces 17% more greenhouse gas
emissions than regular oil it also
leaves behind toxic pools of chemicals
which are poisoning lakes and rivers and
they've been linked to rare forms of
cancer in wildlife and people but it
doesn't just affect Canadians because
that oil will be moving all the way
across the continent the Keystone XL
pipeline would carry this oil from
Alberta Canada all the way down to the
Gulf of Mexico the oil industry touted
as the safest and most advanced pipeline
but it's gonna cross over the Ogallala
Aquifer so environmentalists worried
about leaks and oil spills on top of the
environmental concerns Native American
groups and ranchers are also against the
pipeline because it will cross over
their land
even asking Canada has the world's
third-largest oil reserves and the u.s.
is its largest customer so building
pipelines equals energy independence
from foreign sources and more jobs but
not really still the oil lobby is
gung-ho but at least one company is
having doubts because extraction is so
expensive oil prices need to stay over a
hundred bucks a barrel to even make it
worth it and even if the pipeline isn't
approved the rising global demand for
oil means the tar sands is going to find
a way out
Obama said he'd only approve Keystone if
it does not significantly exacerbate the
problem of carbon pollution hmm what do
you think you should do
you